[Music]
when one is confronted with a situation
that's truly zero-sum where one party's
gonna win and the other party's gonna
lose a situation is very complicated and
sometimes difficult to analyze game
series spent of much of its early days
analyzing zero-sum games and trying to
figure out what's the best strategy it's
a little complicated because it depends
critically on how sophisticated you
think the other party is if they're very
very very smart the chances that you're
gonna out-think them are not very high
in such a situation oftentimes the best
strategy is very counterintuitive
because it involves flipping a coin
rolling a dice or doing something random
professional poker players know this and
they oftentimes advocate in poker
strategy books that one should
occasionally do something completely
counterintuitive in order to keep your
opponents off guard and in fact game
theory has shown that this is a good
solid mathematically well-founded advice
that often times what you want to do is
engage in a kind of random strategy game
theorists call this a mixed strategy in
order to make sure that your opponent
can't get the leg up on you the nice
thing about these random strategies is
that they ensure that your opponent can
never out thank you so even if you think
your opponent's a little smarter than
you or a little bit more sophisticated
than you or has a little bit more
information than you do the fact that
you're being random to a certain extent
means that they can't out thank you now
how do you figure out how to be random
I'm not saying just flip a coin all the
time or whatever what game theorists
have figured out is that in zero-sum
games the best strategy to pursue when
you're against a sophisticated opponent
is to adopt the strategy which minimizes
your maximum loss this is sometimes
called the minimax strategy so the idea
is you think what's the worst-case
scenario for me what could my opponent
do that would make me worse off and then
you figure out what's the best strategy
against that so you're minimizing your
maximum loss game theorists prove that
if you use this way of thinking
minimizing your maximum loss you ensure
that
matter how sophisticated your opponent
as you've guarded against the worst case
scenario and not only that but in
zero-sum games you've done the best you
can possibly do that's not true in games
that aren't zero-sum so one has to be
very careful about employing this
strategy because if you're mistaken and
you're not in a zero-sum interaction you
can end up ruining it for everybody
but if you're truly in a zero-sum
interaction this is one of the
strategies that you can use now suppose
that you're dealing with us suppose
you're dealing with an opponent who's
not sophisticated you're smarter than
they are
there it depends very much on how smart
are they can you out think them and
what's the individual interaction that
you're engaged in so poker players to
return to the example of poker players
poker players will engage in
interactions where they're trying to
think well does does my opponent think
I'm going to Bluff here yes or no and
maybe I'll do the opposite but that's
going to depend on how smart is your
opponent what are they thinking about
and the individual interaction that
you're engaged in game theorists have
actually proven although it's not very
helpful but game theorists have actually
proven that there's no one-size-fits-all
strategy in a situation where you're
dealing with an opponent who is not very
sophisticated
[Music]